[Musique]
c'est un camp de fortune qui s'est
établi à quelques mètres seulement de la
barrière de barbelés à la frontière avec
la pologne nous sommes devant une
opération de déstabilisation de l'europe
piloté depuis l'extérieur ce que subit
la pologne dont les frontières sont
aujourd'hui en état de siège porte un
nom une invasion on a acheté ce visa en
turquie on est arrivés légalement en
biélorussie on n'a pas de problème ici
selon les européens cette crise est donc
monté de toutes pièces par cet homme le
président biélorusse qu'il qualifie de
dictateur c'est une attaque migratoires
il faut avoir conscience de ce qui se
passe c'est organisé par le régime
biélorusse qui fait venir un certain
nombre de personnes c'est un trafic
d'êtres humains aminata diallo est en
garde à vue depuis hier entendu après la
violente agression d'une de ses
coéquipières jeudi dernier alors qu'elle
rentrait ensemble d'un dîner caire à
amraoui a été roué de coups au niveau
des jambes par deux hommes qui se sont
enfuis il n'y a pas un homme
providentiel ou une femme providentiel
qui va sauver la france c'est à vous
d'aller voter et ce qui me me choque
parfois j'ai envie de secouer un peu un
citoyen c'est de leur dire vous avez
entre les mains de chacun une part de la
france alors allez voter au lieu de
manifester aminata diallo vaut la
joueuse qui était soupçonné de
complicité dans l'agression de sa
coéquipière keira amraoui ressort libre
de sa garde à vue personne ne peut lui
parler eric zemmour aujourd'hui en fait
parce que ils le sentiment d'être le
général de gaulle réincarner et donc
monsieur macron est en train de terminer
mon expression sucer la droite
si c'est là la roue de la droite et evra
et qu'il et autocentrée et qu' il y là
il a des ailes et qui n'a pas
l'expérience peut-être que nous avons
que moi j'ai en tout cas de dire
attention attention aux mirages hubert
germain sera inhumé cet après midi au
mont valérien le dernier compagnon de la
libération est décédé le 12 octobre
dernier à l'âge de 101 ans son cercueil
a été extrait ce matin de l'église saint
louis des invalides
le cercueil du berger en inquiète donc
qui donc en train de quitter les
invalides et qui va être voilà posé sur
ce chat amx-10 nommé bir-hakeim le
dernier des mille trente huit compagnons
de la libération avait formulé un voeu
que son convoi s'arrête au pied de la
statue du général de gaulle sa façon à
lui de lui dire
mission terrestre accompli mon général
une dernière entretient pour dire mon
général le travail est fait je rejoins
maintenant les braves au mont valérien
et sous l'arc de triomphe alors qu'on
voit emmanuel même désormais kamala
harris
impact dans trois deux un impact
à 20 ans à peine il quitte à tous ces
terre drômoise sa famille ses amis pour
gagner londres et bientôt avec honneur
et fidélité
se couvrir de gloire à bir hakeim le
cercueil de l'illustre combattants
arrivent au mont valérien
principal lieu d'exécution des
résistants
[Musique]
le chant des partisans résonne dans
cette crypte un caveau avaient été
laissés libres attendant le dernier
survivant compagnons de la libération il
ya un an apprenant donc qu'il était ce
dernier hébert germain avait aussitôt
fait savoir qu'il acceptait cet honneur
vive la république
vive la france
c'est un français qui a battu le record
hier rémy ouvre à rester debout sur sa
montgolfière à 4016 mètres d'altitude il
a assuré qu'il voulait se rapprocher de
là où était thomas pesquet